What I want to do in this video
Is to review some of the techniques to do mental gathering.
Now, if you see something like 355 plus 480,
If you have some paper around, you can
Writing these numbers and doing your traditional way of combining,
But you may be able to do it in your mind,
So how do you do it?
Well, way of thinking about it,
Can we add or subtract these numbers?
So it becomes one of these numbers
A little simpler?
If for example, I have 480 here.
What should I do for
So, to say, we get 500?
It's almost 500.
Well, I can add 20 to 480, but I can not add only 20.
I will also have to subtract 20,
So what happens if you subtract 20 of 355 and add it
To 480?
So what am I talking about?
If this will be the same thing as,
So let me subtract 20 from this.
If those will become 335
And let me add 20 to these,
If 480 Plus 20 equals 500,
The reason I put 20 and 20 added
I said, well, what should I add to 480?
To get 500?
I could have done it in my mind.
Well, I need 20 extra.
355 Less than 20 equals 335.
But now this issue is much easier to reckon with.
335 plus 500,
Well, the output would be three hundred plus five hundred,
Will be equal to
800 and then our 35.
835.
Now, to make what we've done a little clearer,
Remember, we wanted to subtract 20 from here
And we set it here,
If we can divide 355,
We could have said it would equal,
Will equal,
Let's make it to 335
And 20, remember,
The reason why optional 20 is due
I'll add it to 480,
But I will take it step by step here,
If plus 480,
And now I can change the order with any number will add,
If I can say, this would be equal
Plus 20
Plus 480,
Instead of collecting 335 and 20 first,
I can collect the 20 and 480 first,
If I can combine these two numbers first,
And so I will have,
This will be equal to 335
Plus, what is the output of 20 plus 480?
Well, that was the whole idea.
I chose 20 to get 500.
20 Plus 480 equals 500
And then, now, you can bring them together.
This will be 835.
If this is just a longer way to explain what you've done here.
I took 20 of 355,
So i can convert 480 to 500.
Let's do a few other examples of these,
And remember, the key is just thinking about
How to combine or subtract from a setup
To make them simpler?
If here, I have 18 plus 704.
So there are several ways we deal with this.
One way, we can try to make 704 equal
700.
So, we can say that this is the same thing as
18 plus,
I can write 700 plus 4,
Or I can write it as 4
Plus 700, so,
And then I can put brackets around this first,
And then I can only change the order that I collect,
If this is the same thing as 18
Plus 4
Plus 700,
Now I can collect 18 and 4 first.
Now what is the result of 18 plus 4?
He 22, and then I have 700,
And now these are easier to calculate more,
All these will be equal to each other,
So let me just type it like this.
22 plus 700, I can do it in my mind.
That would be 722.
Now, know what you're thinking.
Well, this is supposed to be a technique to do something
in my mind?
I can not write all this stuff in my mind.
The reason for my writing is this way
Is to see what really happens.
But you can do it more quickly.
You can only say, well, let me take 4 of the,
I close my eyes now as I speak,
Just to appear I was in my mind.
Well, let me collect 4 to 18 and subtract 4 out of 700,
Well that would be the same if you collected 4 to 18,
This will be 22,
And if you subtract 4 from 704,
That would be a plus of 700.
22 plus 700 is 722.
Now, there is another way to solve it.
You can say, well, let me in fact,
Instead of subtracting 4, let me add some numbers,
Some values ​​here, so get,
I do not know, to say 710.
So it seems less perfect to me,
But you can do it.
Well, let's see, if I collected 6 to 704,
I will arrive at 710.
So what if you took 6 out of 18
And collected it to 704?
If I can write it like this.
I can say that 18 are 12 plus 6
And then 704 plus
This is the same as 12 plus 6
Plus 704,
And then I can collect these first,
I can get 12 plus 710
And I might say,
Well, that would be 722,
But this way here does not seem
Very close to being as intuitive as doing these,
Try to convert 704 to 700
Take 4 here and add it
Here.
Let's do another example of this.
If 275 plus 595.
Well, my instinctive reaction is,
Can we convert 595 to be equal to 600?
If these will be equal to,
So if you collect 5 to 595, it will produce 600.
Let me do the same thing.
If I will collect 5 her to get 600.
I have a problem converting colors.
If, 600,
But I can not only collect 5,
Ali also has to subtract 5 from here,
If subtracting 5 from there, that would be 270,
If these become 270 plus 600,
And this is easier to calculate in my mind for me.
These will be two hundred plus six hundred
Worth eight hundred.
I have seven scores plus zero ten,
If 800, then I have no one.
870.
Now, another way you can try to solve
Like, let's try to convert these 275 into,
Let's try to convert it to 300.
So, we can say this is the same 300.
We can say the same thing as 300.
And to get to it, I just added 25,
But if I add 25 of this number, I will have to
Take 25 of this number.
If I can ask 25 from here,
And then I will get 300 plus 95 minus 25
70,
If this would be 570.
570, and these are also easy to calculate.
300 plus 570 equals 870.
There are other ways you can use to solve these
The traditional method involves writing them on paper
And so on.
But I hope this gives you a few tools
In order to have the ability to solve these things in your mind.